uh
time is running out
the prophecies say fimble winter leads
to ragnarok
war is coming
my story doesn't end hiding in these
woods
i should be out there finding out who i
am who loki is
i will not allow you to pick a fight
with god
i don't want to fight anyone
i just want answers
and if those answers lead to war with
asgard
maybe that's what mother won we do not
know what mother wanted
well
i don't recognize that double expression
anywhere
odin's got tricks up his sleeve we
haven't dared to consider
what if there was someone who could help
us
you mean here
the old god of war in these lands who is
dead
well for a dead man odin seemed pretty
keen on seeing he wasn't found
if he's out there
we gotta find him
come in
what in all yarns be the happened to him
we're trying to stop ragnarok to help
people
and what if the only way to do that is
war
war is not the only way
stop thinking like a father for a moment
and start thinking like a general
you seem like a calm and reasonable
person
are you a calm and reasonable person
[Music]
in moments of crisis
panic does nothing
harness it
[Music]
let it serve you
here
are you coming with us
[Music]
you'll get your answer soon enough
[Music]
well some of them
[Music]
for as long as i can remember i have
looked for an equal
one who could push me
one who could surprise me
one who could even beat me
yet all i found
is disappointment
will one of you
finally give me what i desire
yes
we
will
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
it's coming for me
whatever you do
don't go out in the dark
stay in the light
the deerfest guests have already started
to arrive just ran into one on the ferry
a famous artist no left
alice
alice
my wife alice she's missing calm down
last night i woke up to a nightmare
i was missing a week what had happened
to me
i squeezed the flashlight like my life
depended on it
with it i could save myself
i could save alice
coral
ducky pleased to meet you
my name is alan wake
i'm a writer
[Music]
um
what was that
there remains work here down down
when forced to face
it [ __ ]
steal your fear
i will be her salvation sorry
the time is nigh
the world rests on the precipice
of transformation
a new age will dawn
peace is a lie
that is what the sith believe
they promised power
now they wield it
we face the greatest sith in generations
they must be stopped
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
i'll let you in on a secret but i'm a
pretty big deal
real big deal
we are getting out of the city homer i
promise we'll go somewhere that loves
cats
no more fights
clean air bright skies
wait wait wait stop stop
whoa
[Music]
where on earth is this
asia
who's there and technically not earth
well not you would call this anyway i
swear to god [ __ ] show yourself show
myself i've shown where are you right
here at the end of your arm
oh hello yes
[Music]
okay so let me get this straight i'm
somewhere that's not what i would call
earth
i'm seeing a freaking dragon and oh yeah
i'm talking to a cop
did i just do that
wait i just moved it with my freaking
mic
yeah okay that is something i do now i
do magic kill jacked up beats i'll
probably fly next
no you're just being ridiculous oh
that's too far good to know there's a
line
suffers you are the only hope we have
you're special
you're the one that's planning on facing
off with sylar
tantasyla is the strongest and most
formidable of all the taunters
you will be doing our land a great
service by killing her
[Music]
frey
no name for a demon
i am the one you seek the one and only
tantasyl
guardians
of the galaxy
you came here seeking truth
rejoice
the matriarch wishes
to share it with you
united in the light of belief all
suffering all grief will end
oh
what's wrong with you oh i think
yeah i think i'm having a heart attack
cease this at once
osmo how are you doing
of the church buddy truths during that
ritual with the priests they kept
talking about a promise
it was like they were drinking funky
juice or something or joined the cult so
let us investigate for you
[Music]
not fun kind always ball
hey world mind long time no see the
current probability of defeating the
universal church of truth is
0.3
is that bad
it sounds bad
i hope you got one hell of a speech plan
peter that makes two of us
follow me
by rejecting the promise
you have proven yourselves unworthy and
you must be destroyed
that was completely intentional the
milano's on her way
thanks bud
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you